>> TED CRUZ GETS AN UNEXPECTED
WELCOME AT THE AIRPORT.
SURROUNDED BY A GROUP OF ANGRY
IMMIGRATION PROTESTERS.
THEY SLAMMED HIM FOR CONDITIONS
AT THE BORDER.
WATCH THIS.
>> AMERICANS WILL NOT BE SILENT.
AMERICANS WILL NOT BE SILENT.
FREE THE CHILDREN.
FOR THE CHILDREN.
>> Juan: SENATOR APPEARED
UNFAZED BY THE SITUATION.
EVEN STOPPING TO TAKE A PICTURE
WITH FANS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CHAOS.
DANA, HOW WOULD YOU HANDLE THIS?
>> Dana: MAY BE NOT AS
GRACIOUSLY AS HE DID.
HE HAS A GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR.
THIS EITHER TURNS PEOPLE AWAY
FROM RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
THE FACT THAT HE IS UNFAZED
SHOWS THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
LEVEL, AS A CONSERVATIVE, AS
SOMEONE WHO CAN JUST SORT OF
DEAL WITH IT, NOT OVERREACT TO
COME BECAUSE IMAGINE HE HAD.
THAT VIDEO WOULD BE EVERYWHERE.
I THOUGHT HE HANDLED IT RIGHT.
I'M UPSET THAT IT HAPPENED TO
HIM.
>> Juan: HE IS AN ELECTED
PUBLIC OFFICIAL.
PEOPLE SHOULD SPEAK TO HIM.
>> Greg: DID NOT AIRPORTS,
ONE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Juan: , BECAUSE HE MIGHT BE
LOOKING FOR A CINNABON.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TIME THIS WAS, BUT ANY TIME, IN
THE AIRPORT, ACTUALLY, NOT A
GOOD IDEA, PROBABLY.
BUT THIS KIND OF THING IS NOT
EFFECTIVE.
THEM CHANTING, FREED THE
CHILDREN.
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO PUT THE
CHILDREN?
THEY'VE BEEN TAKEN AWAY FROM
SEX TRAFFICKERS.
THEY'VE BEEN PREVENTED FROM
SENDING BEEN SENT TO SEX TRAFFIC
SENDING BEEN SENT TO SEX TRAFFIE
SENDING BEEN SENT TO SEX TRAFFIS
SENDING BEEN SENT TO SEX TRAFFI.
CUSTODY IS NOT A GOOD ONE
EITHER.
>> Juan: BUT IF WE LOOK AT THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE MATTER, I THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT
SEPARATING CHILDREN FROM PARENT
PARENTS.
>> Katie: THEY ARE NOT ALWAYS
>> Juan: THE QUESTION IS,
SHOULD OUR POLITICIANS BE DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
>> Greg: YEAH.
FIX THE BORDER LAWS.
THUS WITH THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN SAYING FOR ABOUT A YEAR,
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE
NOTHING.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
SOME GUY TAKES HIS PHONE, AND
THERE WAS A PICTURE OF A DEAD
MIGRANT BABY, FACE DOWN IN THE
RIO GRANDE, AND HE SHOVES IT IN
MY FACE, AND HE GOES, DON'T YOU
CARE ABOUT THIS?
OF COURSE I CARE.
>> Greg: OF COURSE DOMINIC
SORRY ABOUT THAT
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT SAVE
LIVES.
THOSE ARE COMPASSIONATE IDEAS,
AND THOSE ARE THE KIND OF THINGS
THAT GIVE EVERYBODY SECURITY AND
SAFETY ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER.
THESE PROTESTERS, THEY DON'T
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THE FLORAS
AGREEMENT.
OR THE FACT THAT DEMOCRATS
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR SIX
MONTHS WHILE REPUBLICANS WERE
ASKING FOR MONEY TO HELP THIS.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
TRAFFICKERS OR THE FACT THAT THE
MIGRANTS.
THE NARCOTIC SMUGGLERS GO THE
OTHER WAY.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT.
THEY JUST WANT TO CHANT AND GET
IN YOUR FACE.
>> Greg: MAYBE THEY DIDN'T
CARE.
SEE TWO I THINK WE BOTH CARE AND
EVERYONE WANTS TO FIX THE
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: THERE'S NOTHING CRUEL
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
THEY COULD BE TRAFFIC.
>> Juan: OH, STOP.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THAT'S A
GOOD IDEA, JUAN?
>> Juan: THAT'S THE ISSUE.
POLICY PUT IN PLACE BY THIS
PRESIDENT, DO DOMINIC TO IN FACT
TRY TO DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM
SEEKING ASYLUM.
GREG, GET IN HERE.
SPACE MXP TO THAT IS THE
EMBODIMENT OF TWITTER.
THIS IS THE FOOTBALL NOW THAT
THEY CAN USE.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE NOT PLAYING
ANYWHERE.
THAT BOTHERS ME.
OF COURSE A LOT OF FREE.
LOVE IT.
BUT, THE AIRPORT IS SACRED.
PEOPLE ARE THEIR WORST SELVES AT
THE AIRPORT.
AND THEY ARE THEIR WORST SELVES
AT PROTESTS.
AND HE DID SOMETHING FUNNY.
HE WAS AT AN EVENT THAT
ATTRACTED LEFT-WING PROTESTERS.
WHAT DID HE DO?
HE ROLLED ABLATED OVER THEM AND
INVITED THEM TO BREAKFAST AT
APPLEBEE'S.
THAT'S WE NEED MORE OF.
>> Juan: GREG, YOU CAN'T GET
IN THERE UNLESS YOU ARE GOING